je sais pas si vous avez déjà essayé de
parler dans un rendez vous galant de
théorie monétaire
france le fait pas
le croyions ma longue expérience c'est
complètement contre-productif
c'est dommage parce que la monnaie c'est
un sujet passionnant et la monnaie c'est
une institution
qui connaît en ce moment même une
transformation profonde une
transformation historique qui nous
concerne tous
savaient qui à travers les millénaires
les gens les hommes ont utilisé toutes
sortes de choses comme monnaie des
coquillages des pierres des feuilles de
tabac des grains de maïs des métaux
précieux
et aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la monnaie
est dématérialisé mais c'est pas
tellement ça la particularité de notre
époque la particularité de notre époque
c'est que la monnaie est devenu très
facile à produire et peut-être trop
facile est ce que vous savez comment est
produite la monnaie aujourd'hui
essentiellement à travers le crédit
bancaire puisque les banques ont le
droit de produire de prêter plus que ce
qu'elles ont en réserve les banques ont
le droit de prêter plus que ce qu'elles
ont en réserve et comment un complice
telle cette prouesse ce miracle en
créant de la monnaie de la monnaie qui
est créé à partir de rien ex nihilo
alors bien sûr elles le font dans des
conditions qui sont encadrés par la
puissance publique parlement
gouvernement banque centrale
mais justement le fait que la monnaie
soit aussi facile à produire aussi peu
coûteuse à produire créer pour la
puissance publique une tentation presque
irrésistible
d'autoriser une création monétaire
massive notamment à son profit pour
compléter ses ressources au delà de ce
qu'elle peut obtenir par ce moyen de
financement habituel qui est l'impôt
et quand la monnaie était lié à une
objectif y ait là une ressource physique
il y avait donc une limite naturelle à
la quantité de monnaie qu'on pouvait
raisonnablement créé
mais cette limite aujourd'hui elle
n'existe plus et il se trouve que ces
dernières années on a créé de la monnaie
dans des proportions astronomiques
extravagantes et ça commence à poser des
problèmes
d'abord ça dit lui l' épargne des gens
qui ont travaillé et qui ont mis de
l'argent de côté donc ça dissuade les
pagnes ça encourage la consommation et
donc ça favorise la société de
consommation
deuxièmement ça crée une économie de la
dette tous les acteurs sont endettés ça
donne un pouvoir particulier aux acteurs
financiers ça financiarisé le
capitalisme
troisièmement ça perturbe le
fonctionnement de l'économie parce que
ça crée des cycles économiques
artificiel
et puis surtout ça crée de l'inflation
de l'inflation des prix qui est
profondément antisociales
parce que d'un côté la hausse des prix
sur les marchés d'actifs immobiliers
action avantage les détenteurs de ces
actifs des classes aisées ceux qui ont
pu s'endetter pour acheter un
appartement des actions mais de l'autre
côté la hausse des prix des biens de
consommation pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat
des plus modestes des gens qui ont des
revenus modestes
et puis à ça tout cela s'ajoutent des
questions qui se posent sur ce système
monétaire dans lequel nous vivons
d'abord des questions politiques est-ce
que vous avez voté pour ça est ce que la
politique monétaire a fait l'objet d'un
débat lors des dernières élections est
ce que les banquiers centraux sont
responsables devant les électeurs quand
ils font des bêtises
est ce que c'est bien satisfaisant d'un
point de vue démocratique
et puis des questions techniques est ce
qu'il est normal qu'on ne puisse pas
faire de micropaiement sur internet est
ce qu'il est normal qu'un virement
bancaire
internationale prenne plusieurs jours et
que parfois il fallait même signé un
papier technologie du moyen-âge est ce
que c'est bien satisfaisant à l'heure
d'internet où tout est instantané donc
vous voyez que ça fait beaucoup de
questions beaucoup de problèmes et
beaucoup de gens commencent à perdre
confiance dans les monnaies officiel
dans notre système monétaire il se
demande combien de temps il pourra tenir
comme ça
d'autant plus que depuis une dizaine
d'années il ya une solution alternative
qui est en train d'émerger une nouvelle
forme de monnaie qui est en train de
prospérer et qui propose de répondre à
ces problèmes et de répondre à ces
questions ce sont les crypto monnaie
leur particularité c'est de fonctionner
sur internet de manière décentralisée
sans organisme central et sans tiers de
confiance
la plus connue c'est toujours le bitcoin
c'est la plus ancienne et c'est toujours
la plus valorisée d'un point de vue
financier alors le bitcoin il suscite de
sacrés fantasmes pour certains c'est une
occasion de devenir riche rapidement
sans effort pour d'autres c'est une
créature maléfique c'est le mal incarné
il faut s'en méfier le réguler et si
possible détruire qu'est ce que c'est
fondamentalement le bitcoin c'est de
l'or numérique si vous détenez vos codes
de bitcoin personne je dis bien personne
ne peut vous saisir vos bitcoin sans
votre autorisation
comme une pièce d'or dans votre poche et
puis il ya un nombre limité le bitcoin
qui est prévu tout comme il ya un stock
d'or physique qui a limité sur terre
personne ne peut créer plus de bitcoin
que ce qui est prévu par le protocole
informatique et c'est ça la prouesse
technique absolument étonnante de la
technologie bitkom un objet numérique
non duplicable rares et cette rareté
relative évidemment elle le rend apte à
conserver de la valeur dans le temps
voie à prendre de la valeur
comme l'or surtout par rapport aux
monnaies officielle qui en ce moment
sont en train d'être créés sans limite
alors où en même temps moi je suis pas
là pour vous conseiller d'acheter du
bitcoin
il faut bien s'informer avant de le
faire mais le problème c'est que c'est
un sujet sur lequel il ya énormément de
désinformation
toutes les technologies les plus
révolutionnaires les plus radicalement
nouvelles ont toujours mis beaucoup de
temps à être comprise
et acceptée
des observateurs et des acteurs du monde
ancien
on l'a très bien vu avec internet et
c'est évidemment encore plus le cas pour
un sujet aussi sensible que la monnaie
prenons quelques exemples
on parle parfois de monnaie virtuelle
qui ne repose sur rien mais quelles sont
elles ces menait virtuels qui ne repose
sur rien
est-ce que ça n'est pas l'euro est-ce
que ça n'est pas le dos là puisqu'on a
vu tout à l'heure que les monnaies
officielle était créé à partir de rien
alors cela dit c'est sans doute vrai de
beaucoup de crypto monnaie il faut être
lucide là dessus
beaucoup d'entre elles si ce n'est la
plupart sont des arnaques mais je crois
pas que ce soit vrai du bitcoin le
bitcoin sur quoi repose t-il avant
d'être une monnaie c'est un dispositif
informatique qui est composée de
milliers d'ordinateurs c'est très
physique qui consomment de l'énergie
c'est très physique et qui dispositif
qui rend un service totalement nouveau
qui n'existait pas qui n'était pas
possible avant l'existence du bitcoin
qui est de conserver de stocker de la
valeur sur internet sans tiers de
confiance sans risque de censure c'est à
dire sans que personne ne puis ne puisse
interrompre et censurer la transaction
ça c'est totalement nouveau c'est un
service nouveau et la monnaie bitcoin
repose sur ce dispositif tel tir saint
valeur de la valeur que chacun peut
attribuer à ce dispositif donc en
d'autres mots dire que le beacon ne
repose sur rien c'est une affirmation
qui elle même ne repose sur rien
deuxième exemple le sujet de la
consommation énergétique le beacon pour
fonctionner nécessite une forte
utilisation d'électricité pour alimenter
ses ordinateurs qui font des calculs
cryptographique à tence
mais cette utilisation d'électricité
elle est utile puisqu'elle permet de
sécuriser ce réseau
par ailleurs elle est de moins en moins
carbonée aujourd'hui 60 % de
l'électricité consommée par le bitcoin
provient d'énergies renouvelables cette
proportion augmente et il ya même de
plus en plus de cas où l'industrie du
bitcoin rang viable économiquement
des unités de production d'énergie
renouvelable qui ne serait pas rentable
sans le bitcoin
vous voyez que contrairement à ce qu'on
entend à l'idée reçue le bitcoin le
système hilton est en train de devenir
un atout pour la transition écologique
autre aspect la volatilité c'est vrai
qu'à court terme son prix varie
énormément il vaut mieux avoir le coeur
bien accroché
c'est un inconvénient
mais c'est un inconvénient qui est
transitoire et qui est parfaitement
compréhensible dans cette phase de
transition où nous sommes le marché n'a
pas encore trouvé de prix d'équilibré
pour cette chose si nouvelle si
difficile à appréhender qu'est le
bitcoin mais mécaniquement et
logiquement si l'adoption et la hausse
du coûts à moyen terme se poursuivent
normalement la volatilité devra diminuer
dernier exemple
l'argent du crime qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui la monnaie dans laquelle se
font les trafics internationaux
le blanchiment d'argent le financement
du terrorisme
le dollar
l'euro dans des proportions écrasante un
petit peu le bitcoin aussi mais dans de
toutes petites proportions et pourquoi
c'est très facile à comprendre
sur le réseau beaton une transaction est
traçable facilement par des moyens de
police massifs consacré orientées sur
des transactions suspectes
donc vous voyez à travers ces exemples
que la réalité est très éloignée de
l'image anxiogène et péjoratives qu'on
reçoit des médias la réalité c'est quoi
la technologie du bitcoin se renforce il
est en train de surmonter ces
limitations initial l'adoption du
bitcoin se renforce dans le monde entier
des dizaines de millions de personnes
font le choix de détenir du bitcoin pour
se protéger contre l'inflation des prix
et pour se protéger contre l'arbitraire
dans les régimes autoritaires
de grandes entreprises décident de
placer une partie de leurs liquidités en
bitcoin pour se protéger de l'inflation
des états commencent à adopter
officiellement le bitcoin comme monnaie
nationale
est vrai que si cette évolution se
poursuivre mais
ce sera un événement historique majeur
ce sera un événement comparable à
l'émergence d'internet qui pourrait
changer beaucoup de choses qui
pourraient peut-être en une économie
notre économie plus prospère plus juste
plus efficace plus saine peut-être moins
polluante que notre économie actuelle
qui a fondé sur la tête l'inflation la
surconsommation
peut-être que ça favoriserait davantage
de souveraineté des individus face aux
excès de certains états ou de certaines
grandes entreprises gaffard grandes
banques
en tout cas c'est mon impression mais
finalement à la limite peu importe mon
opinion ce qui compte c'est que vous
vous fassiez une opinion ce sujet parce
que l'avenir de la monnaie les
transformations actuelles de la monnaie
concerne votre prospérité et celle de
vos enfants vos libertés et celle de vos
enfants le type de société dans lequel
vous aurez envie de vivre
alors saisissez vous de ce sujet de la
monnaie ne vous laissez pas imposer des
solutions toutes faites notamment par
les experts du monde ancien les
banquiers les politiciens les
économistes les journalistes et si vous
faites cet effort de vous apprendre de
vous approprier ce sujet de la monnaie
vous rendrez compte que contrairement à
l'image
qu'on peut avoir à priori c'est un sujet
beaucoup plus intéressant beaucoup plus
passionnant beaucoup plus crucial
beaucoup plus central et même beaucoup
plus exaltant
pourquoi pas aussi plus glamour
plus glamour
vous êtes d'accord je vais là ajouté sur
mon profil kinder